he came into the room
and um
started touching me in kind of the way
uh the the joking way that he had been
doing for for months which i had many
times told him not to
and had even like hit him a couple times
and pushed him away from me but this
time he like actually
got on top of me
[Music]
i
was born actually in um eastern canada
um and when i was six years old we moved
to utah in the united states
which for those who don't know is like
the capital of mormonism
mormonism at its at its core is that
they believe like the full
um gospel of jesus was lost from the
earth for almost like 2 000 years like
after he and his original apostles died
and that it was restored through this
guy named joseph smith in upstate new
york in the
early 1800s there's a bunch of stuff
that allegedly happened like joseph
smith having a vision of god part of
that was
that he
translated this
ancient
book of scripture
um about people in the america the
ancient americas of god's dealings with
them
called the book of mormon i wasn't
allowed to go on dates at all until i
was 16
years old even then it was not supposed
to be like i wasn't supposed to have a
girlfriend
or anything like that which i totally
broke that rule plenty of mormon
uh
like leaders over the years have given
like speeches about you know only allow
media into your home that's like
uplifting or whatever so like hardcore
metal and like uh rap which are three
styles that now i happen to really like
um were all like off the table for me
you know the lyrics are all about sex so
it's evil or you know something like
that once you become an endowed member
of the church actually there's i'm sure
you guys have heard of the
magic mormon underwear as it's referred
to um
which is you know the temple garments so
after you go through this
temple ceremony for the first time
you're expected to wear
these under clothes it's a white
white bottoms and a white undershirt
for both men and women for mormon youth
and and just mormons in general um
any
any sort of sexual relation um outside
of like a man and a woman who are
married it's seen as a sin they'll teach
like young woman you know you need to
cover up and
um
not be showing like most of your body
because if you do then you'll be giving
young men like
impure thoughts
and um it's that
i know i hate it it's a it's a huge um
kind of purity culture honestly it lends
itself to rape culture so if you if
you're a mormon youth and you like
masturbate or watch porn um
which
normal
uh normal teenage boy of course i did
those things um
if if you confess to that or you're
caught like it's considered as a pretty
serious sin that you have to like
confess
and another
aspect of that upbringing was as a guy
especially being
raised with this expectation that i
needed to serve
a full-time two-year
mission
for the church
and that's really common
in mormonism as well
so i was 18 years old
uh when i went on
a mission for the church i got called to
uh brazil
you don't get to choose where you're
going as
as a missionary for the church you don't
have much contact with your family
except for like email once a week and or
letters
if you want to do those and then two
phone calls
per year once on christmas and once on
mother's day that lack of
contact with your family is like very
hard on a lot
of these young men and women who are
serving mormon missions and definitely
led to a lot of mental health issues and
especially for a lot of the things that
i
ended up struggling with and going
through on my mission um it definitely
made it more difficult feeling like i
didn't have
anyone
to turn to
mormon missionaries you you always go in
twos you always have a companion who's
your work partner basically and you live
together eat together work together um
sleep in the same room not in the same
bed um
but you're basically like roommates for
however however long you're together
right
my trainer happened to be from paraguay
and we got there the first day and had
all like the orientation meetings and
whatnot and they assigned us to
our trainers and he seemed like
a really nice guy
a big smile and stuff give me a big hug
um
but you know it didn't take long
for some weirdness to start happening
he'd like accidentally
touch me somewhere
he would like pretend to be gay or
something and uh
and do all these things that you know
made me feel uncomfortable i was like
dude this isn't like stuff to to joke
about and uh i would get upset at him
for that and when i got upset with him
he
would gaslight me like but why i'm just
kidding dude like what are you what are
you talking about um
and and all these things he'd give me
the silent treatment for days um
which is really difficult in a country
where
you don't um
really speak the language very well yet
and your mission companion is supposed
to be like you're one person that you
can trust and like talk with and so by
the time i had been in the mission for a
couple months he had really
he was a masterful manipulator and he
had done a really good job at
kind of wearing
my emotional and mental defenses down we
got home from having run some errands or
something and it was our weekly
preparation day we got back to our
apartment and i like laid down on my bed
thinking i'm gonna take a nap
and um he came into the room
and um
started touching me in kind of the way
uh the the joking way that he had been
doing for for months which i had many
times told him not to and had even like
hit him a couple times and pushed him
away from me but this time he like
actually
got on top of me
and i froze up um
which you know it may seem surprising
because the guy actually wasn't even
like physically bigger or stronger than
me
but he had done such a good job at
manipulating me and wearing down my
mental and emotional
defenses and energy that i at that point
i was just kind of like froze up and uh
he
sexually assaulted me um he
went down on me without my consent and
then afterwards
um
blamed me for it
which was
very confusing for me at the time
especially considering how
how the church treats um
homosexuality
and um
still to this day
calls it a sin
yeah it was it was definitely uh very
difficult it was definitely kind of a
special kind of hell that i started
going through especially because um
after that first time that he assaulted
me
he did it again multiple times
for the rest of the time that we were
mission companions which i think was
about another month and a half he did it
to me a few times
while i was sleeping i remember waking
up a couple nights with him like
on top of me and thinking like what the
hell is going on
i know part of me wanted to
report it as well
but i also remembered you know the
multiple times where he said like oh if
you tell anyone that i've been like
assaulting you or whatever who's gonna
who's gonna believe you and i've since
learned that my trainer abused other
missionaries that were his companions
[Music]
it's very telling to me
that once you go public about
leaving the church how many people will
just
shun you for a lot of people when they
leave the mormon church like
they'll be disowned their family will
cut them off their family will treat
them as if they're
like super evil
or um just this uh like
this judas that stabbed them in the back
you know just for deciding to believe
something different in terms of like the
official part of leaving the church like
paperwork and stuff so if you just stop
going to church as a mormon um they will
send people after you and what i mean by
that is like they'll send um members of
the local congregation that you live in
to like check up on you and be like hey
are you okay like
we haven't seen you at church like we
want you to come back and also
understandably a lot of us
who leave the mormon church are
angry in a lot of ways about it and
upset because
i mean you imagine
being taught something is true
your whole life and then finding out
it's not um
what's what's that saying my whole life
is a lie you know and that's something
that people will often jokingly say
um but uh
for me that was actually something that
felt quite real um at at one point and
that's just it's devastating it's
absolutely devastating to go through
that i've been out of the church for a
little over two years now
um and it's been
uh
seven
going on eight years since
i was um getting sexually abused by my
mission trainer and um for the past
year and a few months i've been i guess
almost the past year and a half i've
been
in therapy
um consistently with a great therapist
i've been able to process a lot of my
traumas and um and do a lot of healing
and you know there's still always going
to be things to work on i think
personally
but it's definitely been really
empowering
and
as far as where i'm at now with my life
working working on my rock band suit up
soldier um
doing doing other things that i enjoy
just like bodybuilding and uh doing a
lot of outdoorsy things um
going to going to clubs a lot of
weekends and getting wasted occasionally
uh things i could not do when i was
um in the church and you know just
really
honestly enjoying
enjoying my life
my parents would tie us together via a
rope so that we were always together and
i could always make sure she obeyed the
therapist when she heard that story was
just
like really shocked and she looked at me
and she said elizabeth that's child
abuse